it's really just bullshit here in this one
yes Heerlen you know how it is
just bullshit and yes what bullshit then
well quarrels among themselves
cycling from each other
steal and if so
from each other too
yes just from each other
I was at the station once in the evening
and then we ran into someone
it was walking around with a knife
and luckily there were police and stuff
but say
things like that often happen in Heerlen
at train station
a man at once
he looks at me like that
sticks his tongue out at me
then I say so to
what are you doing get away from me
I say so go away
he comes to me
he still does it
I say go away
dirty guys
so you live here yes
what is so nice about Heerlen
I don't like Daniel at all
I sincerely think that the station is the most beautiful
I think they made it very beautiful though
the station yes
so that people can leave quickly
yes yes yes indeed yes